[Applause]
and finally new rule the person the
world needs to hear from most about the
attack on salman rushdie the person with
the strongest moral voice on the issue
of islamist inspired violence is salman
rushdie
[Applause]
and the fact that he can't speak right
now shows us that the wrong side won
this round and make no mistake there are
two sides to this and no they don't
break down to muslim and non-muslim
there are many brave muslims and many
cowardly stupid liberals if all you can
muster to say about this event is
stabbing is bad and i'm against it
without looking at the reasons behind it
you're useless
and that just
[Applause]
and that describes pretty much the
entire mainstream media and here's where
the tweets start coming at me hey bill
not every muslim is responsible
of course they're not no serious person
ever said they were this is what's
called a straw man argument
where a person doesn't engage with the
actual points being made but brings up a
completely different point that was
never being contested to begin with
if we are for example discussing how
technology has made our lives easier and
i say the smartphone is a wondrous
device and you say so you support
toddlers working in sweatshops
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's a straw man argument even though
i do support toddlers working
inspections
but the straw man argument has been used
so often with this issue that i'm
discussing here tonight that i thought
instead of letting strawman's misleading
arguments go unrebutted
i'd invite him on the show so please a
nice round of applause for strawman
ladies and gentlemen
see
there he is
there he is
there he is
he does
and he's man spreading
[Laughter]
stay there
nice to have you on the show i
appreciate you coming i i hear you had a
difficult flight
i know those overhead bins can be very
uncomfortable
anyway there's someone i want you to
meet
this is silvana fardos she is the mother
of the young man who stabbed my friend
when she was asked what she now had to
say to her son miss vardo said i have
nothing to say to him she said i'm done
with him
okay that's a hero
that's courage
[Applause]
savannah fardows could have spewed the
kind of weasley crap we heard from so
many faint-hearted writers after the
charlie edbo massacre
nonsense about how those murdered
cartoonists had it coming because they
were punching down and well yes a room
full of corpses but on the other hand
those cartoons were offensive
but she didn't do that
she had the guts to say i give no
quarter to people who think like that
even when it's my son
now am i saying every muslim house is
harboring a terrorist no
what i am saying is liberals instead of
screaming islamophobia every time
someone points out the unique right that
islam demands to kill you if you insult
their god
you should be supporting people like
silvana fardos
and the vast majority of muslims who
came to this country because they didn't
want to live under this kind of thuggery
and theocracy
ms fardo said her formerly outgoing son
returned from a 2018 trip to the
hezbollah controlled region of lebanon
returned a religious zealot and a
changed man which raises the question
what happened in lebanon did he stay at
the holiday inn express
am i saying everyone in lebanon is a
fanatic no
but hezbollah
their idea of moderate is a hijacker
with an emotional support dog
[Applause]
we can't have we can't have exceptions
for violence based on religion in a free
country we get to opine on religion or
anything else without the threat of
violence and i'm not
and i'm not the bad guy for calling out
the excuse me i'm still talking
and i'm precisely saying they're not all
bad guys
[Applause]
also i thought victim blaming
was something liberals hated why do
their values always get turned around
when religion is involved
women's rights gay rights
protecting children
separation of church and state
and free speech
look
i don't know if you get to the theater a
lot
but there was a show a few years ago you
probably remember the show we all
remember it was fantastic on broadway it
did very well the book of mormon you
remember this show
it's uh
it poked fun at the mormon religion and
and even more offensive had music
no no no no no let's not kid each other
look my friend
we both know what would happen if you
tried to put on a show called the book
of muhammad and poke gentle fun at islam
and no again i'm not saying
most muslims would want to bomb that
theater but just as certainly
some young man would
and saying so does not make me an islam
let me finish
[Applause]
forget it but silvana fardo she's who
liberals should be supporting salman
rushdie will survive because he's not a
keyboard warrior he's a real warrior
but i worry if this country's commitment
to free speech will do the same
you